that's a very special person
international master John Donaldson
multi-talented actually one of my early
coaches really with Maurice all right
well John is known across the chest
world for his incredible knowledge of
chess history also of course as the
ever-present captain for the u.s. squad
at the Olympics and also as an
all-around nice guy
so John welcome back to the show thank
you very much why are you here in st.
Louis this time you just had the US and
world chess Hall of Fame inductions and
also just here to do a little work for
the world chess all of Fame well before
we get to that let's talk a little bit
about the great team effort in Astana
the world team we didn't have all of our
top players but some players did go and
represent Lenderman who just drew
Nakamura he was there for sure what was
your experience in this event it was
really really satisfying as you alluded
to we didn't we weren't at full strength
there were several conflicting events
there was a tournament Prague that Sam
Shanklin was committed to there was also
tournament st. Louis the st. Louis
classic that was at the same time and
then also some players because the turn
was on such short notice
they you know and because of the fact
that the US Championship started five
days after Astana
ended and it's like 30 hour journey door
to door you know front and back it's
understandable a lot of players decline
but US bench is pretty deep these days
so even though we had to completely go
to player number 15 we ended up tying
for fourth we beat China for the first
time in over a decade and our top two
boards Darius Weir's and Sam said Yan
was playing the US Championship those
two and their debuts for the US team had
performances of 27:52 and 2762
respectively out of 17 games they lost
one on first on the first two boards and
Darius like he played again stud you
know gang and Napoleonic rule cosplayers
and he's not even playing in this
tournament
yeah it's true it's true it tells you
how strong US
and that's what I want to say you have
seen these US Championships for decades
how do you contextualize this one having
seen so many stars go through u.s. ranks
and these amazing championships this is
by far the strongest championship ever I
mean you've got five players in the top
30 in the world competing in it and
you've also got a bunch of young stars
that are probably underrated like you
know Sam I mentioned but you also have
Jeffrey and a wonder so it's really
really strong but I should also mention
it wasn't just the US team that did well
in Astana the u.s. women also did really
well and three of the players there Tata
eV and also Sabina and charissa they
doubled up and are playing the US
Women's Championship as well but we also
had a Rochelle whoo-hoo at the age of 12
was the youngest ever US representative
in a team tournament at this level and
she had a 2380 performance rating in
that tournament
oh you're oh yes exactly yeah yeah yeah
so if times are changing
it's done change and we're looking at
the youth movement happen in this
tournament and it seems like it's no
surprise oh seven of the representatives
and the women's are under or teenagers
yeah okay some can't vote can't drink
all of them Thank You Lea but they can
play some chess dropping moves well
let's get to the world chess all the
fame you were there at the induction to
see these these great names getting
inducted to keep a Rubenstein we
mentioned Susan holgar of course got a
mark tamaño what's your feeling when you
come to such an event to see history
being memorialized well you know the
thing is you you're you you have a great
player that you know about during your
lifetime but especially as you get older
sometimes you realize that players that
you remember when you were younger
they're like the newer generation
doesn't remember them at all and I think
one of the things about the world chess
and US chess Hall of Fame's is that it
sort of means that these players are
always going to be remembered you know
and and you know 50 years from now
somebody's going to visit the st. Louis
chess club and they're gonna go upstairs
and they can say yes you're Sara Juan
you know and they're gonna learn about
him and what a great player he wasn't
what a great representative was for the
game yes we'll still be around
well 50 years 50 years
I mean modern medicine doesn't have
these miracles tell me you also donate
to the world chess all the fame you is
it just artifacts some dollars so us how
much I really like this I really love
this place because I think that you want
there to be some place in the chess
world and and I should say first off
that one of the things that makes chests
so special is that unlike other games
like you know like say poker or or
bridge it's the rich history and
cultural background of chess you know
that you know there's there's all these
artifacts that associated with the game
that would it add to it and make it such
such a such such a wonderful experience
and so to my mind you need to have a
place that's a proper report posit or II
for it that can preserve the materials
that you know has the expertise to do
that and also to be able to put them on
display and and the world chess Hall of
Fame can do that in space so I feel you
know so happy that I have a place to
donate you know you know my chess
treasures I love the way you threw a
poker under the bus there Jennifer
sitting there so you're just making
everyone in the panel everybody equally
and how could people donates it to the
world just all the vacant go to the
website and they can go to info at world
chess HOF dot org and they can just
shoot it the staff there any email and
they'll give them all the details in II
thank you so much you didn't throw me
under the bus at the time I'm sure you
would John Donaldson always